well there are many questions and we are
expecting to get the inspector general's
report any day now and that could have
many of the answers that some of these
lawmakers are looking for meantime the
president first tweeting about Andrew
McCabe the number two man fired before
his retirement Andrew McCabe fired a
great day for the hard-working men and
women of the FBI great day for democracy
sanctimonious James Comey was his boss
and made McCabe look like a choirboy
he knew all the lies and corruption
going on at the highest levels of the
FBI meantime on the mulher probe the
president tweeting over the weekend the
mother probe should never have been
started in that there was no collusion
and there was no crime it was based on
fraudulent activities in a fake dossier
paid for by crooked Hillary and the DNC
and improperly used in FISA Court for
surveillance of my campaign witch-hunt
why does the Muller team have 13
hardened Democrats some big crooked
Hillary supporters and zero Republicans
another damn recently added does anyone
think this is fair and yet there is no
collusion so it was a busy weekend on
Twitter and elsewhere let's bring in our
panel guy Benson political editor at
townhall comm Marv lisen national
political correspondent of National
Public Radio and Molly Hemingway senior
editor at The Federalist Molly a fallout
from McCabe and then the comments about
the Muller probe well I mean it is never
a good thing when you're number 2 at the
FBI is fired for bad behavior I mean
what he has suggested is that this is
related to him leaking and lacking
candor about it actually might be much
bigger than that and there would be
reason to think it is much bigger than
that he has had a series of problems
related to leaking and manipulation of
processes and investigations so it was a
huge hit for this larger narrative I
mean what we were told a year ago was
that our intelligence chiefs and the the
highest people at our intelligence
agencies and law enforcement agencies
were apolitical nonpartisan Boy Scouts
who had a very legitimate reason to be
worried about Donald Trump and a year
later we've had all these firings
removals reassignments and you have you
know on Twitter you can see people
tweeting kind of in a crazy fashion
against this president that narrative
looks patently absurd now
looks like a much different story than
we were told a year ago more well I
think what's really interesting is the
president's reaction to this there we're
gonna find out the reasons why McCabe
was fired when as you said the IG report
came out but he was doing a kind of
victory dance in the end zone then he
started attacking Muller for the first
time by name and then one of his
personal lawyers issued a statement
saying the Muller investigation should
end that has never happened before up
until now the White House has said they
were cooperating so then became an
uproar as the president getting ready to
fire mother I don't think so I think
what's happening is he is intent on
discrediting the Muller investigation so
that whatever Muller comes up with he
can dismiss it as you're speaking about
John Dowd who said what he said trey
gowdy a congressman was asked about that
this weekend I think the president's
attorney frankly does him a disservice
when he says that and when he frames the
investigation that way Chris if you look
at the jurisdiction for Robert Mahler
first and foremost what did Russia do to
this country in 2016 that is supremely
important and it has nothing to do with
collusion so to suggest that Muller
should shut down and that all he is
looking at is collusion if you have an
innocent client mr. Dowd act like it
guy yeah I think that's a fair point for
Gotti to make what strange is this
conflation that we're seeing of Muller
and Anna McCabe firing these are in my
view separate issues although the
president is connecting them in a lot of
his fiercest critics ironically are also
connecting them but when you look at the
McCabe firing I think you can make a
very strong case based on the facts that
he would have been fired regardless of
who was president and you know
regardless of the whole Muller
investigation even if it didn't exist at
all because the malfeasance that is
alleged apparently against mr. McCabe
occurred in the 2016 election and that
investigation the IG probe was launched
before Donald Trump became president and
it was a an Obama appointed Inspector
General who came to the conclusions
about what McCabe did and last but not
least the person who made the decision
or the office that made the decision to
recommend firing him
was this ethics office at the FBI that
was completely nonpartisan and the woman
who runs it was appointed by Bob Muller
on the merits it looks like this was
misconduct that McCabe is responsible
for back in 2016 it should have nothing
to do with Muller yeah
I think what Gowdy said was also kind of
weird I mean it is possible for federal
investigations to go off the rails and
it has happened before you can talk to
Richard Jules family about that he was
the guy targeted by the FBI they leaked
his name and basically ruined his life
before finding out that he wasn't
responsible for the bombing in Atlanta
Robert Moeller and James Comey
themselves were involved in the worst
botching of an FBI investigation ever
which was going after the innocent man
Steven Hatfill in the anthrax killings
and they oversaw that and we're quite
confident about it and Ted Stevens the
senator from Alaska who had his
conviction vacated due to gross conduct
by the FBI I think Muller was also a
head of the FBI at that time so
sometimes investigations can go off the
rails and it's incumbent upon an
attorney to actually say that and to
defend his client if an investigation
has the president has involved himself
in a way that no other president has
urging the Department of Justice to make
sure that combing that McCabe was fired
before he qualified for a pension which
happened about 26 hours before he would
have qualified and then connecting the
McCabe firing with the Russia
investigation
McCabe would be potentially a witness
and an obstruction of justice case
because he's true that the president has
complied with the Moller probe for over
a year and no no there's no connection
but if you know there's no collusion and
you've been working with them for over a
year and it's still going on in this
narrative is still being pushed to
undermine the legitimacy of a president
I can imagine someone getting pretty
frustrated you know let me just there's
all this uproar about the president
speaking out about Muller for the first
time and speaking about about the
investigation
there was another president who did that
Bill Clinton New York Times February 9th
1998 the White House broadened its
attack today on Ken Starr Independent
Counsel investigating accusations
involving President Clinton and a former
intern calling mr. Starr corrupt and
demanding an independent investigation
of suspected leaks to his office Paul
Begala senior White House political
adviser accused mr. Starr of using the
sweeping powers an unlimited budget of
his office to conduct a politically
motivated witch
hunt of the president and to intimidate
witnesses into testifying against mr.
Clinton I remember that very well and
don't forget the vast right-wing
conspiracy now this is a tried and true
playbook you know you're being
investigated you want to discredit the
investigator I think it's really similar
to Clinton with one difference which is
Bill Clinton didn't go after the FBI and
the president has gone after the FBI and
his tweets this weekend he talked about
corruption and lying at State Department
Department of Justice and the FBI he
really has gone after institutions here
in a way that's I would say the big
difference is the media treatment
because in March a month after that New
York Times headline that you just read
the New York Times headline was White
House's all-out attack on Starr is
paying off so the media was much more
friendly today go clear the to the Bill
Clinton approach than they are this one
last word quickly the other point I
would make is people are saying well
there was pressure from the President to
fire McKay before he got his retirement
benefits or his pension I think that's a
fair thing to point out but if it is
determined by the nonpartisan IG and the
Office of Professional Responsibility
that this man leaked in an unauthorized
way to the media and then lied about it
should that person get a taxpayer-funded
pension that is a completely reasonable
question to ask